vous
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bauchau au haut à
paroles nounours tu es fatigué il vaut
peut être mieux que tu n'aillent pas
voir nicolas est un pr neil mois ne pas
aller voir mes amis
ah non alors je veux patron ne te fâche
pas de nounours c'était pour rire mes
petits enfants chéris up bon le seul jeu
pour les voir papa pom pom poms poms
poms poms poms j'hésitais qu'elle de dia
on va faire une blague à part ça c'est
une excellente idée et moi moi je lui
tire encore la cuisine tara je vais
prendre les affaires de moments dans sa
chambre sans faire de bruit je reviens
bonsoir mon petit du colloque oui et à
seurre nicolau elle est à la cuisine
elle ne prépare quelque chose de bon pas
preneur
ou ou jeu violent l est pas elle est
allée à la salle de bains et sa toilette
chers petits
elle suit nos consoeurs finaux tous les
soirs je fais ma toilette je me lave
bien le temps qu'est ce que je vois sur
la table ce teint poudré n'est pas aussi
nicolas tu ferais bien d'aller faire sa
toilette je dois faire mais si tu veux
manger un peu niais je le dirai à
personne tout ça je le fait que le goût
tu nous le bon vous mangez tout le miel
de mes enfants
vous devriez voir où les filles la cour
pas au mode et m'avait exemple vous
donner à mon fils vient mon petit
nicolas un moment va t'accompagner au
lit bonsoir messieurs fou sinon je
n'avais plus vous voir ici ou ou wim aux
pauvres chéris
perso j moment vous perdu 1 sous lui
mais les curieux cette maman ça y est
les persos japon où les coquins alors je
me disais bien qu'elle ressemblait
beaucoup à pimprenelle cette map on vous
êtes de petits drôles
ben je vous aime bien quand même surtout
si vous vous endormez tout de suite oui
c'est pas mignon
tu vois on dort déjà bonne nuit mon
petit la jettent à la lumière
fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allons les enfants il n'est plus l'heure
de se déguiser ou de faire des farces
il est l'heure d'aller au lit comme
nicolas et pimprenelle et de vide hormis
y patron ils m'ont bien la trappe lui
comme d'habitude mon cher nounours et tu
es content oui
j'aime ça tu es un brave nounours aussi
pour te faire plaisir tout est petit ami
seront très sage ce soir bonne nuit des
enfants bonne nuit
mes petits amis fait pour eux
[Musique]
en vain
vous